yeah I think one helpful thing for us to
you is that this project actually
started pretty small I mean originally
we were kind of like oh we're just gonna
do like a five to ten minute you know
video about sort of building a house
from scratch and what that means and and
sort of as we discovered the the greater
movement around tiny houses and we got
more excited about that i mean the
project really kind of grew as we saw
the potential and as we saw you had the
interest coming in from the outside as
well so i think that it's not like we
set out to like oh let's spend the next
two years of our lives building a house
and making a future length documentary
you know it it started pretty small and
kind of grew as you saw the potential
for it and i think adding to that it
there each project has the story I mean
you have a story that you want to tell
but it kind of takes on a life of its
own and I actually think that the story
that we that we wanted to tell kind of
grew on its own i mean it needed to be a
larger film to tell that story you know
as we put together a rough cut that end
up being about 50 minutes and at the end
with still trying to keep it with the
short in mind and it just it wasn't
quite the full story you know and we
were trying to make the format fit to
what we wanted instead of having a fit
to the film and I sucking at something
to keep in mind so the the movie sort of
told you how it was going to be a weave
for that before like a lot of times the
film ends up dictating to the filmmaker
now it just becomes definitely him which
made it easier as the project became
more and more work if it felt like
necessary because we were kind of like
oh but we have to tell the full story
how can we not tell the full story even
if it's a lot of work definitely yeah I
think that's something that's probably
more common in documentary filmmaking is
just because you're finding the story
you guys are gonna and and it turns out
the story that we found you know
required a longer format so
you